مخيم ابو شوك بات عنوانا لازمه النزوح
بولايه شمال دارفور
قصه الطيب تلخص حاله كثير من الكسر التي
اثرت البقاء في المخيمات لانعدام الامن في
القرى
فترسم عواطف صوره قادمه عن واقع النزوح في
المخيمات
15 سنه في المعسكر وقيلا زياده من 150
وطبعا
حكومه دارفور اكثر من مليونين نازح
بالاقليم نسبه قابله للارتفاع في ظل تدهور
الاوضاع الامنيه في كثير من ولايات دارفور
الاف الاسر النازحه في مخيم ابو شوك هذا
تامل في عوده الى ديارها في مختلف قراشما
لدارفور 20 عاما مضت ولم تطمئن انفسهم بعد
فبين وقت لاخر يندلع الاقتتال القبلي
فتحرق القرى والممتلكات لكن تحقيق امل
عوده طوعيه يقتضي تدليل العقبات الامنيه
والحياتيه
واقع يتطلب تحركا حكوميا ودوليا للحد من
تاثيرات ازمه النزوح واللجوء هنا تسعى
حكومه اقليم دارفور عبر هذه الورشه لوضع
رؤيه تمكنها من انفاذ برنامج العوده
الطوعيه لسكان المخيمات
بالتنسيق مع اداره الاهليه والحكمه المحلي
ومع الولايه بالنسبه لخدمات الاساسيه
نستطيع ان نوفر بعض المعينات ولكن
المشاريع المصاحبه هي طبعا دي مشروع دولي
متعلق بالنازحين واللاجين في الامم
المتحدهم واعتقد انه ان شاء الله سيتعاون
معنا في هذا المجال دور الامم المتحده هذا
لتصعد الحكومه
لتوفير الخدمه الاساسيه
وتماسك الاجتماعي
وتعايش السلمي وبرامج التي يساعد
الاستقرار والازدهار داخل المناطق العوده
والى حين المضي في خطوات حقيقيه لانهاء
ازمه النزوح واللجوء تظل تداعيات الحرب في
دارفور تتفاعل على مستويات مختلفه ابرزها
الجانب الانساني نزار البغداوي الجزيره
الفاشر الشماليه دارفور